In such a climate, it's not enough to just give the people a megaphone.
That's why your power and your responsibility to dig and to question...
...and to counter distortions and untruths is more important than ever.
Taking a stand on behalf of what is true...
...does not require you shedding your objectivity.
In fact, it is the essence of good journalism.
It affirms the idea that the only way we can build consensus,...
...the only way that we can move forward as a country,...
...the only way we can help the world mend itself...
...is by agreeing on a baseline of facts when it comes to the challenges...
...that confront us all.
So, this night is a testament to all of you who've devoted your lives...
...to that idea, who push to shine a light on the truth every single day.